welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss in Avengers endgame's final battle
and aftermath at a deeper conspiracy
unfolding in the background Avengers
blood being harvested by Nick Fury and
his skrull associates according to
secret Invasion this is perhaps the most
significant Revelation Marvel has made
about the events of endgame in the past
four years and when you go back to look
at that film it actually lines up with a
number of loose ends I've always been
curious about in particular one new
detail I just discovered that I don't
think anyone ever noticed and I'll get
to at the end of this video now I
guessed it on a few episodes of the
break room this week and they're really
important to me so please check them out
as well as my analysis of Jaws my
favorite movie to watch with my dad over
on the Deep dive Channel and quick note
sag-aftra has informed us that
entertainment journalism Outlets like
new rockstars are allowed to analyze
movies and TV shows without violating
any strike rules this is not a paper
motion of anything we support the actors
and writers on strike and we join their
call to the amptp to come back to the
table and negotiate in good faith okay
on secret evasion this season part of
the shape-shifting alien Scrolls plot
has been to acquire the Harvest name for
an operation orchestrated by Nick Fury
during the events of Avengers endgame to
gather blood shed by The Avengers during
the Battle of Earth using a team of
Scrolls led by graphic nearly every
avenger spilled blood in the battle
of Earth even Carol Danvers in the
aftermath some were sent in to collect
that DNA some with the ability to blend
in nobody knew about them but me
and the collectors led by Sue this very
much recontextualizes how we should look
at the events of Avengers end game in
the aftermath of that final battle Nick
Fury snuck in a whole team of Scrolls to
that Battlefield cleanup operation to
gather Avenger DNA as of episode 5 of
secret Invasion graphic scroll team was
unsuccessful at finding any actual
Avenger DNA as Fury moved its location
to a secret drop site in Finland one of
his many fake headstones that required
his breath to open up showing some DNA
and clear fluid in a vial as of episode
five it's not clear if this is multiple
Avengers DNA if so it was all in one
vial it would surely be
cross-contaminated and very difficult to
extract or if really this is just one
Avengers DNA like Harold Danvers she was
the one that Nick Fury singled out
potentially the most valuable Avenger
DNA because Cosmic radiation and flight
and speed are power sets not currently
represented in the four enhanced DNA
currently in possession by the Scrolls
Groot extremists call obsidian brass
Giant and that covers near
invulnerability and Rapid healing and
limb extension resistance to heat and
Pyro manipulation Big Boy brute strength
and resistance too extreme cold but if
you go back and look closely at the
final half hour of Avengers end game
there are just a number of standout
moments that now come under a different
light for example we don't actually see
Carol Danvers bleed on screen as she
fights Thanos one on one Thanos head
butts her but there's no effect which
freaks Thanos out so he grabs the Power
Stone out of the gauntlet and Carol
makes a hilarious oh face before
Thanos super smashes her out of frame
this is really the worst injury Carol
suffers in the battle and it would have
been the likeliest moment she actually
bled we don't really see her again until
after the battle but in a deleted scene
where all the Avengers take a knee she
does look a little bruised up after that
punch so after Tony Stark dies some time
passes until the Davis Funeral when
every key player really in the MCU is in
attendance including Nick Fury who
you'll notice just watches from the
front porch of Tony's house he stands
apart from everyone else watching
everyone suspiciously as always and now
I think that just aligns with the fact
that Nick Fury now we learned was at
that moment ordering squirrels to sift
through the rubble to harvest Avenger
DNA in fact he may have waited until the
day of the funeral when he knew that the
other Avengers would be distracted
because our man Nick Fury never or
misses an opportunity this video is
sponsored by Helix sleep and yeah I know
it seems like nobody here at new
Rockstar sleeps much but I promise you
we do and thanks to my Helix mattress
I've been getting the best sleep of my
life for years now Helix sleep quiz
makes it so easy you just take the quiz
and Helix finds a perfect mattress for
you I wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Lux Helix
mattress other mattress companies use
fiberglass in their products Helix
doesn't do that he likes even owns its
own 100 fiberglass 3 manufacturing
facility I've had my Helix mattress for
two years now it still feels brand new
it's the best mattress I've ever owned
Helix delivers your mattress right to
your door with free shipping in the US
the mattress comes rolled up in a box
and it's super easy to set up yourself
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
get more than three months to make sure
that you love it Helix mattresses have a
10-year warranty and they even offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix mattress I
think you would too so if you're looking
for a new bed check out Helix sleep you
can click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com new rockstars to get 20
off your Helix mattress plus two three
pillows now in many videos over the
years I have pointed out a mysterious
helicopter in the background of this
scene where Hulk Steve Sam and Bucky
re-engineer the quantum tunnel platform
a helicopter carries some cargo away
from the rubble of the battlefield and I
think now we can assume that those were
the Scrolls of Nick Fury's Harvest
operation we also have to remind
ourselves of the timeline of Fury's
relationship with the Scrolls in the
late 90s Nick Fury met graphic when
graphic was a teenager and recruited
graphic to be part of his clandestine
Network in episode 3 of sacred
Innovation Talos claimed that all of
Fury's Espionage career advances over
the years with shield and Project
Pegasus in 2012 his project Insight plan
and Captain America Winter Soldier even
when Nick Fury went rogue and had a
loose Network known as Fury's crew
around the time of Avengers Age of
Ultron and Civil War Fury's scroll
Partners were there the whole time
helping him but then in 2018 during the
events of Avengers Infinity War Fury of
course dusted as a result of thanos's
snap and everyone who dusted return
right before the Battle of earth when
Bruce Banner snapped the new Stark
Infinity Gauntlet so Fury wouldn't have
had that much time to reorient himself
in the streets of New York realize what
had been going on upstated with the
battle and then get back in touch with
the scroll Network to begin operation
Harvest that would have been a real
quick turnaround in which some of the
Scrolls perhaps graphic would have been
like oh hey Fury we've been getting by
just fine without you over these past
five years do you want us to do what now
who are you to boss us around old man
who's actually five years younger than
he should be it just sounds like these
post in-game weeks were a critical
transition period for Fury and the
Scrolls because not only did Operation
Harvest take place very shortly after
this launched the saber space station
and set up Earth's defenses from orbit
with a different group of Scrolls on
that space station and left it to Talos
back on Earth to do things like make
sure Tony Stark's Edith classes got
handed off to Peter Parker in fact
Fury's very acquisition of those aided
glasses might have been part of
operation Harvest get to all this stuff
before the dodc does and since happy
Hogan swipes some Stark Tech 2 as we saw
in Spider-Man no way home he must have
gone through the rubble shortly after
Fury and the Scrolls did so this week
after end game really I think we should
call Fury's second big week and now
after episode 5 of secret Invasion I
think it would be when the Scrolls
without Fury's consent might have
snatched James Rhodes Roadie War Machine
and had rava the squirrel replace him
I've been saying that the Roadie we saw
in the Falcon Winter Soldier might have
been a scroll but now I think Roadie on
the day of Stark's funeral might have
been one as well I think that's why Fury
was eyeing that duck so suspiciously now
before the funeral procession they
played Tony's goodbye message from his
helmet in the living room for pepper
Morgan happy Hogan and there is a moment
where Rhodey looks over at the others as
if calculating how one should react to
this and then on the dock comes to
detail I never noticed before pepper
lays a wreath on the lake and then look
at Roadie and happy they hug and holy
they totally say something to each
other here and never notice because all
we hear is Alex levustry's music
whatever they said had been muted but
Favreau definitely says something and
cheat will definitely responds I'm not
the best lip reader but it looks like
happy says hey man and then he mumbles
something and then Brody responds it
almost looks like the phrase we took him
home it's something something but the
last word looks like home now I've
speculated before that happy Hogan might
also be a possible scroll candidate
someone who might have been a scroll for
a long time and if Rudy had been swapped
at this point that would make two
Scrolls talking to each other and of
course the idea of home home in my own
skin is an important theme for the
nomadic scroll people so I want to know
what you think about this new
interpretation of Avengers end game and
are there any other Scrolls hiding in
the background that you notice thank you
for watching please subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network and thank you for supporting us
I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
foreign